for prediction I think the mobile
devices are actually going to enable
brands to have a better eat an intimate
relationship now why that's the case is
that you can create advocacy versus just
playing awareness you say it enables
companies brands to create real
authenticity advocacy rather than just
awareness yeah I do and here's the
reason why a native user on a phone will
touch or interact with their screen more
than 300 times a day three hundred times
a day so there are 300 interactions per
day on my screen I would hope that some
of those interactions were with your
brand so I think what it does instead of
just being a place of amplification
because I leaned in and I literally
start to interact with your brand it
creates a very deep authentic
relationship and you can create advocacy
means I'm going to be an ambassador for
their brand when I look at the way
people conduct themselves now at dinner
tables down the street all as you say
looking down the face in the phone do we
want to change that or do we want to
accept it and celebrate it we are all a
connected generation so as much as you
meet people at a dinner table we're all
connected you'll get a linkedin request
somebody will start following you
Facebook requests come through but with
all these digital and all these devices
that have access to I actually feel
quite alone now what I hope to happen is
that because i'm using my digital
footprint to make sure i'm a better
educated human when i'm actually the
dinner table i want to be more engaged
more rounded because i'm using my
experience to make sure i have a
connection not just be connected and i
think it's very different